COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I take a look at
a new networking
algorithm that gives your
clients a big performance win.
Is this tech too
good to be true?
Stay tuned to find out.
If you follow along
with our content,
you probably know that we never
advocate for a silver bullet
when it comes to performance.
There's always a
horde of trade-offs
that you have to
consider before things
make sense for your scenario.
But I'm going to break
my rule this time
and say that you should really
be using a new networking
algorithm called TCP
BBR, which can give
your clients in poor
connectivity areas
as much as a 2x
boost in performance.
And all you have to do is set
a simple server side flag.
See, TCP as a protocol
tries its best
to balance between being
fast and being fair,
with much more emphasis
on the being fair part.
For example, as packet loss
on your network increases,
TCP's backoff
algorithm will reduce
the performance of each
user so that everyone
can share the pipe.
But fine tuning this
balance is really tricky.
With TCP's current
backoff algorithms,
even if you're the only
person using the pipe,
it can underutilize your network
connection by as much as 50%.
This is where TCP BBR comes in.
It's an updated
backoff algorithm
that's designed to respond
to actual congestion
rather than just
simple packet loss,
which means that it's
focused on improving network
performance in the worst
case scenario, when
your network isn't very good.
Now sadly, I don't have access
to a consistently unstable
network.
So for the sake
of our test, we're
going to simulate some
worst case scenarios.
To test things, I set up two VMS
in two different regions, one
to be the client and
one to be the server,
and did a quick iPerf test to
check out their performance.
Then, to simulate
our unstable network,
we run the following TC
command on the client,
which will reduce performance
by increasing packet loss.
Rerunning the test, we see
that this has a dramatic impact
on our performance.
Now that we know what
our performance looks
like in the
problematic scenario,
we enable BBR on
the server, and we
see that our performance
more than doubles.
And to be clear, we only have
to set this flag on the server.
TCP BBR doesn't
require the client
to have the same BBR
implementation running,
meaning that your legacy clients
can get this performance boost
without needing an update.
Not bad for a day's work.
If you'd like to know
more details about BBR,
check out the related article
linked in the description
below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas
content because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]